Today,
we know thanks to DNA testing and thanks
to some exceptionally thorough and
diligent investigations that had been
carried out that many people who have been
convicted and found guilty beyond a
reasonable doubt in both capital and non
capital cases are actually
completely innocent of the charges.
A number of people have come off death
row because they're innocent and a number
of people convicted of
all sorts of crimes,
some of whom have served 20,
30 years have been released because the
work of innocence projects all over the
country as well as lawyers,
public defenders,
and other people.
Uh,
it's a disturbing factor when you look
at how close we've come and I think we
actually have executed a innocent people.
Uh,
so we want to talk just a little bit about
that and what the reasons are for it.
With the guard,
the DNA,
uh,
testimony.
Uh,
this fellow here pictured here,
Kirk Bloodsworth,
uh,
was sentenced to death and
1985 of a horrible crime.
The rape and murder of
a nine year old girl,
a five witnesses tied him to the crime.
Uh,
Bloodsworth said when he was sentenced,
he said,
you are sensing an innocent man,
but he was condemned to die.
Uh,
his sentence was overturned in 1986
because the prosecution had withheld
exculpatory evidence that by
law it was required to give him,
uh,
went to trial again.
Bloodsworth once again is convicted
this time he's not sentenced to death,
but sentence to imprison.
Uh,
as it turned out that when lawyers
later looked at Kirk Bloodsworth case,
uh,
they found that on the close of
the little girl who was killed,
there was a very small Siemens Day and
by then the forensic experts and learned
how to do DNA testing and they tested
the stain and they found it was not Kirk
Bloodsworth.
It turns out this man who
had been condemned to die,
this man who has spent so much time in
prison was absolutely innocent of the
crime.
And as often happens with DNA evidence,
they also found out who
actually committed the crime.
So we're going to look at
some of the reasons why,
uh,
people,
that are innocent,
uh,
are convicted,
and why perhaps we shouldn't put quite
as much faith in the results and the
verdicts that are reached
in the criminal courts.
Uh,
as we do,
uh,
one reason,
and perhaps one of the most
prominent is misidentification.
Uh,
the film that's recommended in the
materials murderer on a Sunday morning,
uh,
involved a young African American
boy who's riding his bicycle in the
neighborhood.
A tourist is shot and killed.
Uh,
the police picked this young man up.
He's black,
he's in the neighborhood.
They take him back to the husband
of this woman who's been killed,
who was of course shake.
And you can imagine you've just seen
your spouse shot right before your very
eyes and watched her crumbled
to the ground and die.
And they bring a black kid and
put them in front of you and say,
is this a kid?
And he says,
yes.
Uh,
it turns out he was wrong.
public defenders,
uh,
that represented Butler prove not
only that Butler was innocent.
Not only was he acquitted at trial because
of the extraordinary lawyering that
was done on his behalf,
but they actually found the
person who committed the crime.
And there was some DNA evidence that left,
no question that this other person
was the one that did the crime.
Uh,
mis identification happens
in all kinds of cases,
particularly in large areas where
people don't know each other.
Of course,
small town,
maybe everybody does know each other,
so it's less likely.
Uh,
and there've been a lot of efforts
to try to improve the way in which
identifications are done.
Uh,
but a lot of one enforcement agencies
had been very resistant to that.
Uh,
how,
uh,
the pictures are presented or lineups.
Uh,
we know that one of the
most suggestive things,
uh,
is to just simply take a person
back one on one a and show him,
uh,
to,
the victim has happened
or the witnesses happened,
uh,
in Butler's case.
Uh,
so misidentification,
uh,
still a reason that,
erroneous convictions are made very
often the person who was arrested,
uh,
having to be in the neighborhood,
that's why they got arrested.
Uh,
but the aren't the person
who committed the crime.
A,
another reason is expert testimony of,
of dubious value.
Uh,
there are a lot of experts who work
at crime laboratories or who testify
habitually for the prosecution.
Uh,
they may be people who are
working in complete good faith,
uh,
and conscientious.
Uh,
but when the crime laboratory is part
of the State Bureau of Investigation,
uh,
sorta develops in some of them at least,
biases,
uh,
that favor the prosecution.
Uh,
they're also honest
mistakes that are made,
uh,
in deciding what evidence may mean,
in trying to foul you.
Wait,
what happened in a case?
I mean,
a good example is Cameron Todd Willingham.
Uh,
this was a man who was
executed by the state of Texas.
He was convicted of an arson,
uh,
in which is three little
children were killed.
Here he is with one of them,
amber on,
on his shoulders.
Uh,
the fire department didn't really
know how to investigate a arson cases.
They very seldom had a arson
cases in this community.
Uh,
the question always in an arson cases
was the fire started accidentally.
Uh,
for some reason or another because of
an electric heater that overheated and
started a fire.
And Chris,
this was in the middle of the night,
uh,
or was it arson?
Was it intentional?
Uh,
the experts in Willingham case that
testified for the state said it was arson
and they gave a lot of reasons for it.
And just one example,
uh,
they said that the patterns on the glass,
that there were all these,
uh,
they call it a craze glass or the way
the glass was cracked and so forth.
It that showed that an accelerant was
used and that was evidence of arson.
Well,
it turns out that,
uh,
glass will end up that way.
Uh,
if you get class very hot
and spray cold water on it,
which of course is exactly what
happens when the house burned down.
Uh,
the house,
the fire heats the glass,
the fire department comes sprays water
on the glass and you get this pattern,
which doesn't show then
an accelerant was used.
It actually shows,
uh,
that,
cold water was poured on high class.
And there were a number
of other examples of this.
There was another case in
Texas involving almost,
uh,
the same,
kind of a fire that,
uh,
Willingham was convicted of.
It involved a fella named Ernest Willis.
He was convicted of arson.
Uh,
he had the very good fortune to have
a New York law firm take his case and
consult with the leading arson
experts in the United States.
And they basically took the prosecution's
case apart and showed that a lot of
the testimony that had come in had been
based upon sort of these myths or these
sort of,
uh,
beliefs that a lot of old
timey arson investigators had.
But that science had
proven we're not accurate.
When this information was
taken to the prosecutor,
uh,
in Willis,
this case,
uh,
the case was dismissed
and Willis was set free.
If you change the lawyers
in those two cases,
if Willingham had had the benefit of
Willis as lawyers and checking out his
case,
and Willis had the misfortune
of having Willinghams lawyers,
uh,
you would change the
outcome in those two cases.
The battle rages on about whether,
uh,
Todd Willingham was actually innocent,
but the weight of the
evidence is certainly,
uh,
daddy was,
another way is prosecutorial misconduct.
Another way in which innocent
people are convicted,
um,
uh,
for you to turn over exculpatory evidence.
We talked about the prosecution.
We talked about the responsibility that
prosecutors have if there's evidence of
medicines,
uh,
to turn it over.
Uh,
there've been several prominent
cases where that's come to light.
John Thompson,
uh,
who won a multimillion dollar verdict,
when it was found that prosecutors knew
that the blood type involved in solving
that particular case was not
John Thompson's blood type
and had known for years.
It was only discovered when he was
just weeks away from execution.
Uh,
his verdict was taken away from him
by the United States Supreme Court.
Uh,
uh,
Anthony Graves,
who was sentenced to death also in Texas.
Uh,
his case was set aside
because the prosecution didn't
turn over evidence of the
key witness saying that graves was not
involved in that somebody else had been
involved when the case came back and
was examined by a prosecutor for,
from Houston.
Uh,
that prosecutor said it was the worst
prosecutorial misconduct she had ever
seen.
This was the prosecutor put
in 19 people on death row.
I mean,
she's not somebody who's terribly
sympathetic to that offense.
Uh,
but what we don't know is how often
these mistakes don't come to light,
uh,
because they're buried
along with the clients.
And that would be the
case of Carlos de Luna.
Uh,
Carlos de Luna was
sentenced to death in Texas.
Uh,
Jim James Liebman and Professor at
Columbia University Law School and others
have a book coming out in 2014,
uh,
regarding the case,
there's a website about Carlos de Luna,
uh,
suggesting that in fact,
the k the crime was
committed by another Carlos,
Carlos and Mendez.
Uh,
and that the prosecution
knew about this other Carlos,
but stood up in front of the jury
and said that the other Carlos was,
didn't even exist.
That it was a myth that
it was just something,
a dune.
As lawyers,
we're trying,
uh,
to,
distract the jury with,
uh,
but,
convincing case,
looking at all the evidence that
Carlos de Luna like Todd Willingham,
uh,
even though he was executed was innocent.
Another reason is false confessions.
It's hard to imagine why a person would
confess to a crime they didn't commit.
But we know that if a person is deprived
of sleep for a long period of time to
private to food is subject to a
very harsh interrogation techniques.
Uh,
we know,
particularly if it's a person who has
a limited intellectual functioning,
although that certainly
doesn't mean all the time,
uh,
that people do make false confessions.
Uh,
you know,
Gary Geiger,
who was accused of killing his parents,
uh,
ultimately after long
interrogation with the police and,
and being asked to imagine,
uh,
how he would have committed the crimes
if he had ended up with what was
supposedly a confession.
Can Imagine how horrible it would be to
lose both your parents to come home and
find your parents dead and then
to be accused of the crime.
And since to death row turned out later
that they found out a motorcycle gang
had committed the crime,
uh,
Earl Washington and sentenced to death
and Virginia with an Iq of about 46 or
somewhere in that neighborhood,
uh,
would confess to anything.
Uh,
and he confessed to committing this
crime for which she had not committed a,
he said one time the victim was black.
He said at one time the victim was white.
He was willing to say just about anything,
uh,
that he was asked to say.
Uh,
he had very limited
intellectual functioning.
Uh,
he saw the police as authority figures.
he very much wanted to please them,
uh,
and he just simply didn't
have the ability to cope,
uh,
with,
with dealing with the questioning.
Of course,
ultimately DNA evidence,
proof that he was absolutely
innocent of the crimes.
And there've been many other
examples that are documented by,
uh,
people who studied,
false confessions.
Uh,
another reason is false
testimony by informants.
Many cases are made,
uh,
by informants.
Very often people in jails
will tell the prosecution,
uh,
if you'll drop my burglary charge,
I'll testify that this person
who was in the cell with me,
uh,
confessed or admitted to
me that they did the crime.
We see this in case after case,
after case after case.
Uh,
and increasingly people are
realizing that this testimony,
this sort of bought testimony,
uh,
is that a lot of people say just about
anything to get out of jail or a lot of
people say just about anything
to get their sentence reduced.
And so,
uh,
the studies have found that,
informants are notoriously unreliable,
but there's no way
juries are going to know.
Some courts now instruct the jury's a
year to be very careful and you're to
scrutinize this testimony.
Uh,
but the jury is still
at the end of the day,
a person says,
I was there.
The person came to me and
they admitted doing it.
Uh,
we know that for example,
in Los Angeles,
they were able to get access to court
records to find out what the details of
the crime were.
So the prosecution would argue,
uh,
he must've confessed because the
informant would not have known the d the
details of the crime if the
defendant hadn't told him.
Uh,
in fact,
the informant had learned,
uh,
from court files,
what the details of the crime where,
uh,
so this testimony,
continues to be used.
It's a very common,
uh,
in criminal cases today.
A poor legal representation is something
that we've talked about in the segments
on council.
Uh,
it remains a tremendous problem.
the best protection against an innocent
person being convicted and sentenced to
death is competent legal representation
is having a lawyer who will investigate
the identification.
A lawyer,
he'll find out everything that can
be found out about the informant,
a lawyer who will check into the
forensic testimony that's being used,
the opinions of whatever it may be,
a medical examiner,
an arson expert,
and then consult with their own experts,
uh,
to see if in fact this evidence stands up,
that in many cases that just
simply doesn't take place.
In many cases,
people are inadequately represented.
Uh,
the government's case is not really
contested because the defense lawyer just
simply doesn't have the resources to
hire the expert witnesses or to do the
investigation that's,
that's needed.
Uh,
they're also procedural barriers
which come into play often.
This evidence is not discovered
until long after the trial.
If it was known before trial,
of course it would be presented at trial,
but long after the trial,
some evidence comes to light.
Uh,
and then the question is
how to get it before court.
Uh,
sometimes,
uh,
Texas for example,
you have 30 days after the trial,
uh,
to file a motion for new trial.
Uh,
there may be an opportunity in
the state post conviction process.
Uh,
but what happens when you get past that,
uh,
sometimes they're procedural defaults in
the case that his issues have not been
properly preserved and then waived,
uh,
because he didn't seem that
significant at the time.
Uh,
but now we know that they are
tied to evidence of innocence.
So,
and then the final thing is what happens
after a person has gone all the way
through the federal review.
The Federal Habeas Corpus Review,
um,
person finds new evidence may be
very critical evidence of innocence,
but you only get to go to
federal court one time,
uh,
with the exception of an innocence claim.
But as we'll see,
a very high standard,
uh,
let's look first at procedural bars.
Uh,
the Supreme Court held that it is a
miscarriage of justice to execute an
innocent person.
Uh,
the court developed at when issues were
procedurally waived or when they were
barred,
uh,
that a person could show cause that is
a reason external to the defense and
actual prejudice,
uh,
and have the issue heard by the court.
But what if the person can't show cause,
uh,
or actual prejudice?
Usually there's going to be prejudice
in the cases that involve innocence.
Uh,
the court has said where the
constitutional violation,
that is the issue that wasn't preserved,
probably resulted in the conviction
of a person who's actually innocent of
federal habeas court may grant the writ,
even though there's no showing of
cause for the procedural default.
And the court has made clear that the
showing is that is probably resulted in
the conviction of an innocent person.
Uh,
the court can grant the writ.
Now it takes a constitutional violation.
That is,
there was a failure to
disclose exculpatory evidence.
It wasn't known until just now.
It's now being brought before the court
and the constitution of violation.
If you look at the facts and the
facts develop from those facts,
show that the person is actually
innocent or ineffective.
Assistance of counsel,
failure of council to do certain things.
And we know now that if
council had done those things,
uh,
the person would be innocent.
So it's going to be a combination
of a constitutional violation and,
uh,
evidence of innocence.
It's got to establish the
innocence of the person.
If that constitutional violation has hurt.
Now let's look at what happens to a
person who doesn't find out about the
evidence of innocence of
the constitutional violation
until after they've been
through the federal habeas corpus process.
Uh,
the supreme,
the Congress did this in writing,
uh,
this part of the antiterrorism
and effective death penalty act,
which was adopted in 1996.
A person can try to bring a claim of
innocence tied to a constitutional
violation,
uh,
but only if the underlying facts,
if proven and viewed in light of
all the evidence from the trial.
All the evidence that we have as a whole
would be sufficient to establish by
clear and convincing evidence,
not probably,
but by clear and convincing evidence that,
but for the constitutional era,
no reasonable fact finder would have
found the applicant that is the petitioner
guilty of the underlying offense,
some much higher standard.
And the law requires that the petition
first be presented to the United States
Court of Appeals.
Three judges here.
It decide based on that hearing,
whether the papers make
out a sufficient showing,
uh,
that the person may be innocent,
and that they can make this showing
by clear and convincing evidence,
uh,
that no reasonable fact finder a
would have found the person goatee
extraordinarily high standard to meet.
If the court finds that,
then it sends it to the District Court
for a hearing in which the evidence will
actually be presented.
Uh,
but it makes it very difficult
to get back into court.
Uh,
once someone has had a
federal habeas corpus hearing,
what about a case in which it's found
that there's a constitutional violation
affecting the penalty phase of the case.
And maybe if this had come to light,
the person would have a stronger
showing a mitigating circumstances and,
and,
and maybe it would not have
been sentenced to death.
Uh,
the Supreme Court has said that in order
to meet this standard with regard to
the sentencing phase,
with regard to the
sentence that is imposed,
the person has to show that,
but for the constitutional violation,
the person would not have been
eligible for the death penalty.
This is almost never going to be the
case because if you have any case where
there's one aggravating circumstance,
uh,
the person's eligible for the death Polly,
it's going to be the very rare case where
the constitutional violations is going
to show that that
aggravating circumstance,
uh,
would not be valid,
although there could be such a case,
uh,
but for the kinds of errors that really
affect the penalty phase of capital
trials,
uh,
no relief either for procedural bars
or in Second Habeas Corpus petitions,
um,
in Herrera versus Collins.
Linelle Herrera,
uh,
didn't have constitutional violation.
He came before the court right before
he was to be executed by Texas and
presented what has been referred to
as a free standing claim of innocence.
Uh,
that is,
he said,
I've got new evidence and the new
evidence shows that I'm innocent.
A bite.
It's not tied to a
constitutional violation.
It's just new evidence.
Uh,
Supreme Court and a decision by
chief justice Rehnquist said the,
in order to bring this
Habeas Corpus action,
uh,
there has to be a
constitutional violation.
You can't bring a habeas case just based
on a freestanding claim of innocence.
But then in order to get the votes
of Justice Kennedy and just O'Connor,
he adds a paragraph,
uh,
near the end that says,
we may assume for the sake of argument
that a truly persuasive showing of
innocence,
uh,
would render the,
execution unconstitutional and
be a basis for habeas relief.
But Herrera's evidence,
uh,
the court makes clear it didn't think
was very strong at all and certainly not
strong enough to make that showing.
Uh,
the court says the fail safe
here is executive clemency,
uh,
and says quite a bit about executive
clemency and the value of it.
Uh,
the problem was in Texas,
there's never really been much executive
clemency because the decisions are made
by an 18 member board that never meets
as a group in facts is things around to
each other.
Uh,
and never really recommends
clemency for anybody.
Uh,
so it's not much of a fail safe in Texas.
It may be,
uh,
in some other places,
justice O'Connor,
uh,
joined by,
Justice Kennedy says,
I certainly say that if
it's a truly persuasive,
a showing of innocence,
that a person should get
habeas corpus relief,
uh,
justice white,
says only if no rational trier of fact
could find proof beyond a reasonable
doubt.
Uh,
Justice Scalia and Thomas,
uh,
say that there's nothing
in the constitution,
nothing in the text and the
traditions of the country or practice,
uh,
that requires the court to entertain
and claim of innocence at all.
A Texas attorney general was
asked her an oral argument.
You mean if there was a videotape that
showed this person was somewhere else at
the time of the crime or showed the crime
and that this person didn't commit it,
you're saying they
could still be executed?
And the answer was yes.
That's what we're saying,
a,
that if there's no
constitutional violation,
uh,
the court has no jurisdiction
and nothing to look at.
Uh,
justice Blackmun joined by justice
Stevens and justice Souter dissented,
uh,
saying that the standard ought to be,
whether in light of new evidence,
the result of the trial is sufficiently,
uh,
reliable,
for the state to be able
to carry out its execution.
So far,
nobody has been able to make a
freestanding claim of innocence.
Some judges on the Sixth Circuit Court
of Appeals thought that Paul House had in
his case,
uh,
but the supreme court,
while finding that house had
made a sufficient showing
to go back and put it on
his claim of innocence,
uh,
found that it was not
a freestanding climb,
but he had constitutional
issues in there as well.
Well,
finally,
we'll just take a moment
and talk about Glen Ford,
uh,
released in March of 2014,
after 30 years.
I mean,
this is what happens when
innocent people are convicted.
30 years of this man's life,
uh,
gone.
This was taken by his lawyer.
This picture of him was
taken by his lawyer,
uh,
on the very first day that he was out
after spending 30 years that the notorious
Angola prison and death row in Louisiana.
Uh,
and you see the reasons for
wrongful convictions in this case,
the lead attorney was an oil and gas
lawyer who had never tried a case,
never tried a case to a jury,
either a civil case or a criminal case.
The other lawyer working on the case
was two years out of law school.
He worked for an insurance defense
firm and he tried slip and fall cases,
cases where,
uh,
people would sue a restaurant because
somebody slipped and fell and broke their
hip or whatever.
He would defend the,
the restaurant for the
insurance company in this case,
which was tried in Shreveport,
Keto parish,
Louisiana.
The prosecutors used all of their strive,
user jury strikes to eliminate
all the black people from serving.
So Glen Ford was tried
by an all white jury.
And as I said,
he went to,
uh,
Louisiana state penitentiary,
the Angola prison,
uh,
spent 30 years on death row there.
And then after 30 years,
the prosecutors announced that
they had credible evidence,
uh,
that Ford was neither president or a
participant or an any way involved in the
robbery and the murder of
the victim in this case,
uh,
30 years of a man's life.
It's a long time,
uh,
at least he wasn't executed.
But what we've learned from what we've
been talking about and so much more,
uh,
is that this criminal courts,
the criminal courts do make mistakes.
Uh,
and very often the mistakes
are found serendipitously.
Uh,
sometimes the people have been exonerated
because the journalism school at
Northwestern law school,
uh,
for people on Illinois to throw are
found innocent by journalism students.
Uh,
sometimes it's DNA testing.
sometimes it's lawyers that do
extraordinary investigations
and work over years
and years and years to finally
figure out what happened in cases,
but many times they're
not those people there.
And what we know is that this criminal
justice system makes mistakes that
innocent people are indeed convicted
far more than people realized,
uh,
that the poor legal representation
is a critical part of that.
But only one part of it,
uh,
that is long as the courts are
making decisions based on things like
identification,
based on things like informants,
those sorts of things.
There are going to be
mistakes and unfortunately and
tragically in some capital
cases,
uh,
without the kind of extraordinary
work that we've seen.
In some cases,
those are going to be fatal mistakes and
innocent people will in fact be put to
death as,
as I think they had been already.